tu ressembles à une princesse il me
tarde Votre Altesse de franchir votre
forteresse alors mais rien ne presse
j'ai bien le temps d'admirer tes fesses
comment ça mon bébé Bernard
oh non j'en ai le caleçon qui compte
Bernard bon moi avec toi je sais à quoi
m'attendre c'est cool record de distance
d'éjaculation de Earth shoots n'auriez
pas vous avez quatre enfants Alexandre
moi j'ai bien visé le
tu as déjà été au bois de Boulogne
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
à la bonne réponse
oui
c'est pas vrai il faut savoir que ce
gars là Horse il a deux passions dans la
vie battre des records c'est la première
et envoyer sa semence à l'autre bout de
la pièce le Marine tient à vous nous
montrer en quoi consiste le cracher de
bigorneau
[Musique]
yes
et c'est quoi votre technique pour
espérer battre le record du monde qui
est de 11 mètres 0,4 rien que ça ah bah
faut donner de l'élan faut y croire il
faut projeter quoi faut être doué
là-dedans moi j'adore
[Musique]
pas en fait tu crois que j'aurais pas
gagné
quoi avec les travestis du mois de
septembre
la première chose que je leur demandais
c'est quel est le dernier animateur qui
est passé vous voir
[Musique]
je sais qu'elle gibule là il est contre
dans sa tête elle rigole quoi Bérengère
c'est un bulldozer elle est là pour
faire la fête pour s'amuser pour
s'éclater j'adore moi c'est pareil je
suis comme toi je suis pleine d'énergie
tiens regarde
[Musique]
marine vous êtes du genre à faire le
grand écart dès le premier soir vous
sympa l'accueil elle arrive à faire des
choses que même moi 30 ans je sais pas
faire elle lève la jambe enfin un grand
écart truc de ouf avant j'étais agent
d'entretien je croyais à la piscine à
chatte la piscine à chatte
[Musique]
[Rires]
et que dire des deux manches américaines
de cyclo-cross à Rochester ce week-end
c'était plutôt
[Musique]
la gadoue donc pour les filles avec
Commodore un petit sauf qui peut
j'ai été voir Casino Royale au cinéma
qui est un James Bond et il y avait la
nouvelle à saint-martiner royale et
j'étais sur les Champs-Élysées et je
vois le film j'ai dit je sors je sors du
cinéma et je vais aller directement
acheter la voiture
donc
Aston Martin Monsieur je voudrais la
somme Martine de Diane est-ce que vous
l'avez oui monsieur casteldi ça j'ai
fait un chèque et je l'ai eu je
connaissais ni le rappeur
ni l'humain et donc on arrive sur mon
bateau et ok on va à l'eau et là il est
parti du niveau zéro mais quand je vous
dis zéro c'est que
c'est quelqu'un qui regarde les algues
qui te disent au frère elles sont
vivantes elles bougent
et donc il avait même pas un cousin par
alliance qui avait mis une paire de
palmes j'ai fait un chèque directement
j'ai pas eu pendant une semaine je l'ai
eu 8 mois après et il voulait vivre il y
a votre nom sur le moteur comme ça et ça
a mis pigeon aussi
et donc et donc j'avais acheté cette
voiture assez cher
380000 euros
vive la France c'est avec ces mots que
Zlatan Ibrahimovic a partagé hier la
bande-annonce du dernier Astérix et
Obélix l'Empire du Milieu et pour cause
l'extravagant footballeur suédois il
incarne le centurion antivirus
Ibrahimovic pointent le bout de son nez
au sein d'un casting XXL aux côtés
d'Astérix joué par Guillaume Canet aussi
réalisateur du film et Gilles Lellouche
en Obélix Vincent Cassel interprète
César et Marion Cotillard se glisse dans
la peau de Cléopâtre à découvrir le
premier février au cinéma
et j'ai voulu la revendre et quand je
l'ai acheté mais vous savez c'est une
voiture extrêmement rare donc je vais je
vous la vends mais vraiment parce que
c'est vous monsieur Castaldi sinon je
vous la vendrai pas donc je reviens un
an après pour dire voilà bah voilà
finalement je m'en sers pas est-ce que
est-ce que vous pouvez pas me la prendre
ça se rebond pas parce que
150000 euros et aujourd'hui elle vaut un
million d'euros